president Trump keeping some praise on
his Justice Department today for suing
California over its shielding of illegal
immigrants sanctuary cities were working
very hard the Justice Department has
done fantastic job I do think we should
have legislation where we put an extra
line in the money that we give them you
want the money you can't have the
sanctuary cities what the mayor of
Oakland did the other day was a disgrace
where they had close to a thousand
people ready to be gotten
she went out and warned them all scatter
so instead of taking in a thousand they
took in a fraction of that very dangers
from the standpoint of ice and Border
Patrol very dangerous she really made
law enforcement much more dangerous than
how to be the sanctuary State lashing
out hard against the administration for
targeting its policy as immigration
policies watch how dare you vilify
members of our community by trying to
frighten the American public into
thinking that all undocumented residents
are dangerous criminals the Attorney
General is trying to distract the
American people from a failed
immigration system by painting a racist
broad brush of our immigrant community
as dangerous criminals it's a bad idea
for him to start talking about anything
to do with the history of slavery or
reconstruction or the civil war in the
United States his credibility is pretty
much shot on those issues California
represents the future and and they don't
like it but there you go
the president plans to visit California
next week for the first time in office
should be an interesting trip Kimberly
yes okay so are we gonna ignore the
obvious well we all wore blue in
solidarity for something that we will
maybe explain later we just forgot
anyway
one of us looks like a smurf not me one
of us looks like Grover that would be me
and Kim really looks fabulous she
bring it yeah we want you to ride us
right yeah
before at best well we know who wore it
best it's obvious okay anyway so oh yeah
so president Trump is going to
California he's gone and I think that
both political bases the left and the
right that this is the issue where they
are not going to agree and so they do it
a lot of people do and they can't agree
can really they're going to court they
are going is gonna win yes well you know
it's this is what happens right and so
California has obviously been and all of
its uh you know leaders from the
governor to the Lieutenant Governor
quite aggressive against President Trump
aggressive against immigration policies
you have mayor's making it a protest
warning illegals if there's about to be
a raid etc so you also have been wanting
to sue him environmentally about the
wall taking a lot of heat about that and
everybody who's running for office for
governor next feels the same way and
wants to see Roque I don't think that's
gonna work out very well for them what
I'd like about President Trump is he's
not shying away from any kind of
adversity he's gonna go there he's gonna
make his opinions known he's gonna check
and see what's going I think it's gonna
be contentious though private protest
etc but ultimately I believe he's going
to prevail on this issue and Greg
California well of course it's politics
mostly lean left there are a lot of
conservatives and Republicans that live
there that probably agree that at least
on the sanctuary city issue and maybe
even the wall that it's a good idea yet
well no it's it's kind of an it we
talked we touched on this yesterday
about you know if you're Californian do
you want your far left leaders to equate
this kind of issue with an issue that
led to civil war I mean when they're
bringing up slavery or when you're
bringing up any kind of civil rights to
take this are you as a Californian okay
with far left activist basically
drumming up an issue to a point where it
could be lead to violence that is
absolutely nuts yet they're doing and I
think I mentioned it yesterday that you
know talking about like our past our
civil war it's slavery 600,000 people
died in the Civil War it's a little bit
irrational to bring up these things when
you're talking about no illegal aliens
and a
federal law you know in sanctuary cities
it's a bit irrational and I'd go back to
the other point I said if you're okay
with violating a law that you don't like
then you better be okay with me
violating a law that you like so can I
have a sanctuary City for open carry or
an abortion free zone what would really
tick off the left okay smoking or how
about this just an entire city sanctuary
City for unborn children a permit to
carry and country music well country
music yes that would drive that would
drive left-wing activist have your own
sanctuary city for death metal yes and
then no one will come to LA later and
it'll be better for you right there with
me America coming music - um okay I had
a great question for you about I really
had a good one he threw me off with
country music so I'll just let you say
whatever you think you want to say I
agree with Greg says one okay moving on
yes because it's kind of a blue Thursday
yeah so my thought is this that there's
so much interesting so many layers this
because as you know President Obama sued
Arizona for violating some of the
federal government's policies with
regard to immigration and he won he won
because the court said that federal law
when it comes to immigration is supreme
and is the law of the land and States
shouldn't interfere california's
response to this though is that they are
not interfering that in fact what
they're doing under the 10th amendment
which guarantees them the right to
protect public safety is taking steps to
make sure one that example private
employers aren't simply trying to avoid
paying people by calling the feds and
saying hey get these guys out of here
before i have to pay them or secondly
that people who are not criminals but
our immigrants are not abused when they
are detained and housed in facilities
sometimes for-profit facilities there's
been a history of past abuse of
immigrants and when it comes greg to
this talk about slavery that was brought
up not by Camilla Harris that was
brought up by our Attorney General Jeff
Sessions who said that the southern
states believe the nullification of
federal law and that's what he said
California was up to I think that there
is here where California is gonna say we
are not trying to nullify any law we're
simply trying to protect the state of
California we're trying to protect that
set of let's well Public Safety because
remember lose even the police chief
today threat to public safety the threat
to public safety is that people feel
like they can't talk to the cops they
can't talk to law and that isn't because
they're in fear for that statistics
backup that's why the police chiefs back
it some police chiefs too and that's
true I say that's why I said some do
what do you think of this Jason because
when you were in Congress this whole
issue in Richmond President Obama sued
Arizona that all took place at that time
one of the most infuriating hearings
that I held was when we had the victims
of the crimes from the criminal element
the point isn't about the the bigger
broader population although if you're
here illegally you're here illegally but
it's the criminal element and eighty
thousand times during the Obama
administration there was somebody that
was incarcerated got entangled with the
law they were convicted of a crime and
then President Obama released him back
out of the United States as opposed to
deporting them and the Democrats in
California are absolutely nuts you're
tell us about it absolutely not we're
talking about taking care of ice
officers that are trying to get rid of
the criminal element yeah and all the
problems and things going on in
California like education and crime and
and not funding their pensions they have
to go out and pass a law saying hey you
your private entity you cannot cooperate
with the federal law enforcement that's
crazy
no I didn't say they couldn't cooperate
their California and they couldn't lose
on this as Kimberly said but they simply
said that they want a seven seat 72-hour
period so that employers are not in the
position of saying we don't want to pay
these guys or we can get rid of these
guys and get a new batch of illegal
immigrants that we can pay less that's
what that's about
no they go they go to great lengths to
protect the criminal element as opposed
to supporting those I saw just say who
put their lives on the line they go to
work I think that you remember that
President Obama was called the DePorter
in chief because he was very aggressive
and by the way the American people are
very not aggressive enough
you have committed a crime and you're an
illegal immigrant people want you out
what we're talking about is red-meat for
the base I think that's what Pelosi said
that's what this is this is Trump and
you're in trouble when you're quoting
Pelosi want Oriole and a Senate election
in California next year and so in some
ways what you're seeing some of the
comments from somebody like the mayor of
Oakland she said how dare you needlessly
endanger the lives of our law
enforcement officers to promote a
radical open borders agenda but is this
issue going to pull all of those
Democrats that are in the gubernatorial
race farther to the left as they try to
win that primary possibly making it hard
for them to tack back to the center I
think it will make them difficult for
them to talk back to the center for sure
but let's be honest if you're looking at
you're talking about the gubernatorial
race you're talking about the current
lieutenant governor right Gavin Newsom
you're talking about I heard of him
Antonio Vieira ghosa
yeah work hard for my endorsement so
both of them are already pretty
decidedly left and but there is a
component down in Southern California
that they're gonna want to try to snag
and grab that base okay but it's gonna
be tough because I think they are gonna
be pushed even further to the left you
see it already in the rhetoric saying
they want to see the president for the
same that they don't want to observe
these policies saying that you should in
fact be warning people when these raids
are happening so they've kind of already
made their choices they've made their
bed and then what happens then for
conservatives in California do they
should they move out their feet well
there is the Gutfeld solution which is
you halt selling California to Mexico
for 50 trillion dollars the rest of
America 49 states gets a three year tax
holiday because that's about 10 trillion
dollars the remaining 40 trillion goes
to solve poverty air pollution diseases
by 2030 America will consider buying
California back but only if they bathe
and I a judge of that
Oh Pablo is considering this he told me
was listening to you in the car and the
radio I know this Larry Kudlow what I
like to National Economic Advisors talk
daily I've never met him he's good
senator grassley or Bob Goodlatte the
chairman of the House Judiciary
Committee should immediately call up the
mayor of Oakland have her raise the
right hand and testify and explain
exactly what went down how did she know
these raids were coming where did you
get that information why did she do it
Congress should put her they'll have it
under oath special counsel